hello and welcome back to Deep dive the
podcast where it's my immense pleasure
to sit down with entrepreneurs and
creators and other inspiring people and
we find out how they got to where they
are and the strategies and tools we can
learn from them to help build a life
that we love now this is a bit of a
different episode because this is mostly
going to be me doing a bit of a Spiel as
a bit of an update as to what is
actually happening with deep dive so we
are now on the e8th season of the
podcast we've been going for over two
and a half years now two years and a bit
and this marks an interesting inflection
point interesting for me but I hope vely
interesting for you as well um in the
podcast
essentially while I have absolutely
loved doing the conversations that I've
done on Deep dive and we've had some
amazing episodes and you know you guys
seem to be loving them as well uh there
is a sense in which doing deep dive
episodes has started to feel a little
bit like a job for me um and this was
never the intention the intention was it
for was for it to not be a job was for
it to be a fun place where I could have
the conversations I wanted to have but
then as it started to grow as we started
to systemize and scale as we started to
try and be productive dare I say with
how we were doing deep dive we ended up
in a mode where it was like I'd be doing
batch filming weeks or I'd be filming 15
episodes in a week and wouldn't really
have time to read the books of the
people who are coming on and then it
would I would be going off a research
Doc and it it turned into sort of this
like conveyor belt of
episodes which is fine if the thing that
you want to do is grow if the core thing
that you want to do is try and grow a
podcast there are people like Chris
Williamson people like Steven Barty Dar
a CEO where the podcast is the main
thing that they do it's like the only
thing that they do well uh only is a
strong word but it's like their main
kind of content output and so they
optimize everything for this sort of
conveyor belt of guests and try and
optimize everything about the episodes
but for me deep dive was never supposed
to be about being a conveyor belt of
episodes it was meant to be to host
conversations that I would actually
genuinely enjoy
having and therefore what I've decided
to do in my recent um kind of change of
heart around like growth and
productivity and optimization and all
that kind of stuff is that we are going
to dial down the optimization dial on
Deep dive so what does that mean what
that means is we might not have an
episode happening every week there are
still a bunch of interviews that we've
recorded over the last year or so that
we're going to be
releasing and what I want the episodes
to be is more opportunistic like let's
say I'm in LA and I happen to be hanging
out with I don't know Jay shessy or
someone and I just be like hey Jay have
you got a few hours do you want to just
record a podcast and we can just hit
record and talk about whatever and I'd
want to be able to do that episode
without worrying about like all the
production value and all the research
and all the title and thumbnailing
similarly I have a lot of Zoom calls
these days with business coaches and
other creators and other entrepreneurs
and other writers and I often think that
there's a lot of really good value
shared in those Zoom calls which no one
else would normally get to hear but I
want to with their permission of course
open- Source some of these Zoom calls
some of these like private conversations
around growing a business or growing a
brand or yeah work life balance or
happiness or money or or fulfillment any
of that kind of stuff
I want to kind of Open Source these
conversations and publish those also as
episodes of Deep dive and really I want
Deep dive to be a place where I can
publish these sorts of conversations
that's what the plan's going to be
moving forward now what might be
interesting is to to look back
on I think a lot of people who listen to
this podcast based on the stats based on
the surveys we've done you guys you know
Aspire for growth you got a lot of you
want to be entrepreneurs you want to
have Financial Freedom you may maybe
want to start a side hustle maybe you're
not like desperate to quit your job but
like you know you want to thrive in your
9 to-5 but you also want something on
the side something that's a bit of a
creative Outlet something that might
have the potential to make
money I think Deep dive is an
interesting case study of this
because it's it's it's an example of
what happens when something starts off
as a hobby and then you monetize and
optimize it so at the start of Deep dive
great interview with Ben Frances great
interview with Shaz who founded mus
match now now known as Mu and some great
episodes with like Dan Priestley and
people like that where I was really just
asking the questions that I wanted to
ask but but then and so that's that's
kind of what a hobby is a hobby is a
thing that you do for yourself I was
asking the questions I wanted to ask
interviewing the guests I wanted to
interview and it just so happened that
we published those episodes online and
people listened in and that's amazing
but then we thought you know what this
seems to be going well and people are
vibing with it and why don't we just get
feedback from the audience why don't we
see what the audience wants to hear
about and we listen to the audience and
then the audience was like okay well we
want this topic and this topic and this
topic so we found people to interview on
this topic this topic on this topic the
audience a lot of them were saying that
like a lot of you guys were saying that
you don't really like it when I you know
for a period of time I had a lot of like
woes wo and imposter syndrome around
writing my book or around like figuring
out what I was going to do with my life
and you guys got a bit bored of those
sorts of conversations cuz I guess for
me what what those conversations were
like and what was perhaps interesting
about that is because at that point we
switched to batch filming the episodes
It's Like on you know in that given week
the thing that I I was struggling with
personally was the thing that I was
bringing up with all the guests but then
those episodes would get sort of
released and sort of staggered over time
so it would look like every week for 15
weeks Ali's talking about the same thing
but in my in reality it was just like a
few days of recording and then we
thought okay well you know there's a
reasonable point we're not doing this
podcast just for fun cuz I can just have
conversations with people just for fun
anyway we're doing the we're doing the
podcast
because because we wanted to add value
to the
audience uh I do apologize with there's
some hammering in the background I
happen to have builders in the house
right now doing up my mom's bathroom
room so we're just going to we're just
going to go for it and I do I do beg
your pardon and based on the feedback
from you guys based on on the feedback
from the audience we were like okay cool
we want to add value therefore let's
mold the podcast to what the audience
wants from us let's make it so that I
ask fewer questions about things that
I'm personally interested in because you
know as it related to entrepreneurship
and build business and brand and stuff I
am like now quite far ahead of most
people who listen to this podcast just
because I've been doing it for a very
long time and been obsessing about it
for a very long time and so a lot of the
questions that I want to ask are no
longer relevant to a complete beginner
for for example and so the podcast
started to change and mold based on the
feedback we were getting from the
audience and at a certain point it
crossed from it being a fun thing that I
do for fun that we just happen to
publish to being a thing that I do for
the
audience that as a side effect I sort of
have fun doing and when when the
enjoyment of it became a side effect
rather than the main reason for doing it
that's when it really started to inch
into that territory of feeling like a
job because really the thing like what
is a job a job is a thing you do for the
sake of some kind of external gain and
the happiness you get out of it is like
uh a happy side effect broadly um
broadly you can argue with that
definition but it started to feel like a
job for whatever that's worth and at a
certain point in a business's growth
like in digestion is more likely to kill
you than starvation so with our business
you know we've got the YouTube channel
we've got the courses we've got the book
and then we also had the podcast on top
of that and the podcast was growing and
growing and we were thinking okay we we
want to get bigger guests we wanted to
to do more things
but it just started to end up it it was
just taking up too much of my time and
too much of my own head space and I
really sat down to think you know if we
could only do one or two things and do
those one or two things really well what
would those one or two things be um it
would be the main channel for sure and
it would be writing books and then it
would be the courses that fund the
business the podcast was like number
four on the on the priority list but the
problem with number four in the priority
list is that as you grow a business you
start to have to make difficult
decisions about deprioritizing certain
things that are not like your top one or
two or even three priorities and deep
dive always came up as you know one of
those things that it felt like it was a
good idea to try and grow deep deep dive
because it's an asset and it was growing
and it's a podcast and it's got
longevity and all that stuff it seemed
like a good idea but after two and a bit
years of doing it my heart stopped being
in it I think because of the amount of
systemization we put into it I've
noticed the same thing with the main
YouTube channel as well the more you
know at I've been doing YouTube for
seven years now and the more yeah at
certain times we've had periods where I
have
been optimizing a lot of the YouTube
channel optimizing the titles and
thumbnails thinking about the algorithm
thinking about retention thinking about
like engagement stats and how to hack
engagement and how to get people to the
end
and there is a you know there is a level
of optimization that takes the fun out
of the thing and with the YouTube
channel I've also cled it back and in
the past I used to have a few writers
who would write videos for me and now
these days I do most of the writing
myself I try and try my best to connect
to the spirit of service and speak from
the heart and I you know every
entrepreneur I spoken to does have this
trade-off at some point there is this
trade-off between doing a thing for the
money or doing a thing for the growth or
doing a thing for whatever external
metric you want and doing a thing that
you resonate with internally this is why
you know you might know people who have
quit high paying jobs on the surface it
seems like a bad idea to quit a
high-paying job because it's like oh my
God you're so lucky like how ungrateful
you are to be thinking about quitting
this you you know all of these good
things are happening it's got such
stability but you know that your heart's
not really in it and this aspect of that
you don't really like and maybe you want
to take a pay cut to do something else
to explore your creative Outlet or you
know all that woooo stuff and your
parents might not be able to get it
they'd be like whoa brv what are you
doing you're like you're like letting go
of this like stable thing that's making
money and you're like doing this thing
to follow your heart like that what kind
of [__] is that but it's that same
kind of drama played out with literally
everyone I speak to and within our our
business as well as you guys may know I
left medicine which was a is a very
prestigious and stable stable and
somewhat well-paying career path to do
this YouTube entrepreneur author thing
that was really weird most people at the
time were like whoa what are you doing
it's kind of weird um but I think
everyone faces that dilemma in our lives
it's not just if you're an entrepreneur
or a side Hustler or whatever like we
all face this dilemma between do I do it
the thing that seems sensible because of
the external externalities associated
with it versus do I do the thing that
involves following my heart and in the
context of the business as much as I
love interviewing people on Deep dive
treating it like a job which is kind of
what we started doing is no longer fun
and I don't want to do it anymore
so I still coming back to what's the
point of this kind of update video
podcast episode
thing I love the fact that we have a
podcast a podcast is freaking sick I
love the fact that I can I can sit down
and have long form conversations with
people I want to have long form
conversations with I love the fact that
if there's a new book coming out the
author of that book is going to be doing
the podcast circuit and may well decide
to come on Deep dive so I get a chance
to talk to them that's really really
really cool what I don't love is the
upload schedule what I don't love is
batch filming what I don't love is feel
as if that has to be done to a
particular Cadence in order to appease
the algorithm or to or because it was a
promise we made to the audience so
what's happening moving forward what's
happening moving forward is that I'm
going to continue having these
conversations and interviews and stuff
but they might be published on a more
infrequent basis we're probably not
going to be doing every week we've got
some stuff in the back catalog that I
think you're going to be super excited
about some amazing conversations and
zoom calls and stuff like that some
business coaching sessions that are a
bit different from just like a
traditional like interview we've got a
sick business coaching session that b
and and I did with Dan Priestley who is
actually our highest performing podcast
guest of all time um that's going to be
really cool because you tend not to see
the inside of what does a business
coaching session look like I've got Zoom
call recordings of sessions I've done
with my CEO coach who's very expensive
or sessions I did with Corey who's a
clinical psychologist who used to be my
executive coach back in the day and
these conversations are the sorts of
things that I think people get a lot of
value from but they don't fit the bill
of a traditional podcast at least in
2024 so those are the sorts of things we
want to be publishing and then you know
sporadically opportunistically when I
happen to be in with someone or having a
zoom call with someone I might ask their
permission to be like hey can I just hit
record and if this is useful we'll just
publish it on Deep dive so that is
what's happening with the podcast now
there is a bunch of you who if you're
still watching this little update video
podcast episode listing thing that you
have been following the Journey of Deep
dive for maybe weeks maybe months maybe
even years you might be part of our
telegram Community which is very fun you
might be commenting on our community
posts you might be commenting on the
episodes you might be one of the various
people who send us emails being like
whoa that episode with Robin way or Dan
Priestley or uh elen or hunter or
whatever changed my
life firstly thank you thank you for all
your support with this podcast it's
because of you guys listening in and
watching and commenting and sharing that
this podcast has grown to the point that
it has become a job because it honestly
it's a good problem to have it's a very
first world problem to have it's like
the Far big you know a far bigger
problem with a business is where you try
something and it doesn't work but in
many ways a harder problem or one that
sort of involves the heart more than the
head is one when is where where you
doing something and people do like it
and it is working but there's something
about it that doesn't doesn't quite feel
right so I'd like to say yeah thank you
for following the journey so far I hope
you'll continue to follow the Journey of
Deep dive because I think some of the
episodes we've got coming up are
absolutely sick um but it's without your
support we wouldn't even be in this
dilemma um so the fact that we are means
I'm enormously grateful because
obviously being here and having the
privilege to be able to make a decision
like winding down or like slowing down
rather than like continuing to go for
growth and growth and growth on an asset
based on my heart rather than my head
that's a very privileged position to be
in and a position that most
entrepreneurs are not in so yeah I just
want to say massive thank you for that
and I hope you'll continue to engage
with the podcast and I hope you'll
actually keep like it's it is it is
useful to hear your feedback you know I
was talking at the start about how how
based on feedback kind of we changed
changed the format of the podcast it
it's still very useful to hear we can
simply choose not to act on it if it
doesn't if it doesn't Vibe with my heart
but a big part of why I'm here and why I
do this stuff is to help people build a
life they love and to genuinely try best
to be helpful to you guys I'm going to
continue to have these Zoom calls anyway
I'm going to continue to do the coaching
sessions and have these
conversations but if I know what you
guys find helpful then it helps me
decide helps me realize oh you know what
actually I'm about to have this
conversation let's just hit record on
Zoom call let's hit record on in real
life let's make sure I've got a nice
kind of microphone you know I'll take
the microphone out of my bag just to
have a slightly better audio quality
because I know there's a possibility
this might be published so yeah
essentially I'm going to do all this
stuff anyway but sort of whether or not
we publish the episodes does depend on
whether whether or not you guys find
them helpful um so if you do or if you
don't then do please let us know and
then we can kind of mold figuring out
like what we publish versus what we
don't publish based on that now over the
years of doing this podcast I have had a
bunch of there have been so many good
things if anyone wants to start a
podcast really would recommend um not
necessarily because it's easy to grow a
podcast but because of the the friends
you make along the way so for example
one of the ones that most you know Ben
Francis was episode number one he's the
CEO of gym shock and the founder of gym
shock and he and I became friends
through him coming on the podcast like
he drove all the way from Birmingham or
Sol Hall rather down to Cambridge and
came to my came to my flat and we hung
out we got a takeaway and he came with a
videographer and he met Angus um and
that was just like really fun it was
super cool to be able to meet someone
like that who I I've I've looked up to
for a very long time it was super cool
meeting Dan Priestley Dan priestley's
books you know I read his books I
highlighted the hell out of them I
thought he was in Australia because then
he was Australian but it turns out he
lives in London and so someone connected
us on Twitter thank you Dan um and
then he came on the podcast and that
episode taught me so much about like you
know how to build a business and helped
me helped me like realized that I've
been thinking about business in this
entirely weird way and that episode got
like 1.5 million views last time I
checked and now Dan priestle has become
a friend and a mentor and he helps us
out when we're struggling with business
stuff and we just hop on a call with him
and he's like done coaching sessions for
our team and everyone loves him he's a
great guy and he become a friend through
the podcast then we did an episode two
with him and that also got like over a
million views because people seem to
love Daniel Priestley
that was amazing it was so good meeting
will mccal the philosopher philosophy
professor at Oxford who wrote the book
what we owe the future i' heard of Will
and knew of him on the grap Vine for
years and then he came and did the
podcast and we had like a 4-Hour long
conversation about like philosophy and
altruism and philanthropy and all that
kind of stuff and now he's become a
friend as well and that's just really
cool and similarly there's a bunch of
other people that have interviewed on
the podcast who have taught me a lot of
lessons one of the key lessons that I've
really learned from it is
that every success F person seemingly
has a period of grind and a period of
Hustle but then the ones who are happy
are the ones who recognize when that
period of grind or hustle is no longer
serving them like to start a business
you kind of have to have that period of
grind and hustle it's very hard to start
a business while you have a full-time
job if you also want to be successful
and if you also want to have really good
work life balance it's just really
really hard to do that I don't know many
people who've been able to do that but
if you're serious about starting a
business or a side hustle become
financially independent or any of that
kind of stuff it does take a period of
hard work where you your life might be
imbalanced but what a lot of these
people like you know now advise is sort
of it's it's like strategic imbalance
you you recognize that in the season of
your life you're in crunch mode and
you're going to grind and you're always
keeping an eye on making sure you don't
get burned out making sure you are
taking appropriate breaks and making
sure that you can can sort of bring your
head above water so that you can survey
the landscape and see is continuing to
grind still useful right now I was in a
bit of a grind phase when I was working
full-time and also doing the YouTube
channel um and I found ways to make it
fun as per the whole like Feelgood
productivity philosophy this is like the
German version which is happens to be on
my desk LOL I found ways to make it fun
but my work life balance was not amazing
when I was working full-time as a doctor
and also you know commuting an hour to
work and back and also trying to have a
social life and also trying to go to the
gym and also trying to grow a YouTube
channel in a business honestly not great
work life balance I was working all the
time it's just the work was really fun
and I found ways to avoid getting burned
out so if you really really really
really value work life balance you are
probably not going to start a successful
business it's just the way of the world
at least that's what I've gleaned from
100 plus entrepreneurs that I've
interviewed on this podcast so far but
if you want to start a successful
business and you're okay with
strategically imbalancing your life for
a small period of time then once you get
to the other side once things start to
work you know it's very hard to get a
business working but once it's working
it becomes a lot easier to sort of take
your foot off the gas and to start like
optimizing a little bit more for balance
so that's been kind of one of the main
takes takeaways um the other really big
takeaway that I took from almost
everyone is that you know I've
interviewed a bunch of people who are
like way more financially successful
than me or like way more famous than me
and or whatever and you know it's what
it's what everyone says like the
achievements and the accolades don't
actually give you any
happiness growing and momentum and
progress gives you a sense of purp gives
you a sense of purpose gives you a sense
of like you you know going forward
you're like making progress It's nice
it's dopamine
inducing but like you know the guy
running a $100 million business is no
happier than the guy running a$1 million
business who is no broadly no happier
than the guy doing a 150k a year Beyond
like below that point it starts to make
a difference because now like you know
that's where you know you have to still
worry about paying the bills and all
this sort of stuff but you know very
quickly when you at least growing a
business you get to the point where
money no longer buys more happiness and
actually running a $100 million business
is generally a lot more stressful than
running a $1 million business so you
know this is something again that Dan
Priestley talks about the idea of a
lifestyle business if what you want is
freedom fund flexibility and decent cash
flow there's no need to try and Grow Big
Beyond like try and grow big at all
costs there's this whole like Silicon
valy mentality that's often in a lot of
these like entrepreneurship podcasts
around growth at all costs but I think
again it's all about strategy it's about
knowing what the goal is what's the plan
and what's the system to get there the
GPS framework it's about recognizing you
know at at what point does growth
continue to serve you and as at what
point does continuing to try and grow at
all costs at what point does that stop
observing you and recognizing when you
need to take a step back in that sense
which is in various ways what I'm doing
with this podcast now okay so so far
we've talked about like two I guess
takeaways in the work domain um you know
a big part of building a life you love
is also health and relationships and joy
and I've had the privilege to interview
a bunch of people sort of on the health
front and also on the relationships
front here on the podcast on the health
front honestly the biggest takeaway i'
I've gotten is find a way to make it
easy so that you can be consistent
something Alex hosi said on the Pod was
something to the effect of look if you
can just hit the gym regularly for like
six months or a year that's what it
takes to make it so that you'll do it
forever and doing whatever you can to
make it easy like these days I do
workouts in the morning and I have a
personal trainer and just realizing that
oh most of these entrepreneur type
people who are very busy they make time
to work out in the morning because if
you do it in the day time it's not going
to happen if you do in the evening that
eats into family time so mornings are
actually a really good time to take care
of your health that's something I've
started doing thanks to advice I've
gotten on the podcast on the
relationships front as well you know we
did a great interview with uh professors
John and Julie gotman uh who do a bunch
of written a bunch of books about
relationships and do research on
relationships and one of the main
takeaways for me from that was how kind
of the importance of rituals you know
one thing I do with my girlfriend is you
know we do regular is relationship
reviews where we ask each other the same
set of 10 questions every time we've
been doing this for years now and it's
great for improving relationship health
and for being a little bit more
intentional about this thing that's
crucial to everyone's lives
relationships um yeah just try to inject
more intentionality into relationships
is something that I've really taken away
from the podcast because it's it is kind
of weird like most people think it's
weird to do a relationship review or to
have like a regularly scheduled date
night where you talk about your finances
or something to that effect um but yeah
a lot of these like relationship expert
and relationship therapists seem to land
on that Insight that hey there is value
in the rituals there is value in doing
stuff repeatedly that you know is good
for you and creating those rituals as a
way to remind you to actually do the
thing okay so just wrapping this up a
little bit um firstly a massive thank
you to everyone who has listened to this
podcast or watched or subscribed or
followed or shared it's because of you
that we're in this very privileged
position to be able to kind of follow my
heart as it as it relates to the podcast
rather than just my head and rather than
just the optimization secondly a massive
thank you to any of our guests we've had
over 100 guests on the podcast so far
they've all been like ridiculously fun
conversations and I've learned something
from every single one and I often take
notes during the podcast then I often
relisten to the episodes back my mom
thinks it's kind of weird that I sort of
watch my own videos but I tend I tend
not to watch my own YouTube videos I
tend to listen to back to my podcast
episodes because it's like oh it it sort
of feels like I'm back there and I'm
learning in real time that's really cool
so massive thank you to everyone that
we've ever had on as a guest and that we
will that we'll continue to have on as a
guest because the podcast is not
stopping it is continuing it's just
going to be a little bit more like loose
in terms of the format at least for the
next season and then we'll review we're
doing this as an experiment and we'll
see how it goes who knows maybe six
months from now I'll decide you know
what actually I really miss doing the
podcast with regularity let's just go
back into it and I might just do that
but I'm considering this next chapter of
the podcast this next season a bit of an
experiment to see how it feels to do
Lucio content with less of an upload
schedule where I mean you know with more
of this stuff around publishing Zoom
calls and Publishing coaching sessions
because I genuinely think that can add
value to people's lives and I think we
can do that in a way that continues to
be fun for me all righty so that's it
for me uh thank you very much for
listening I hope you enjoy season 8 of
the podcast I hope you'll browse the
back catalog of amazing episod episodes
that we've got on YouTube and on Spotify
and wherever you get your podcast
snipped is my personal favorite we
listening to podcasts for the record um
there'll be linked in the show notes in
the video description if you want to
check it out but yeah thank you so much
thank you for your support so far and I
hope you enjoy the podcast moving
forward bye